could you imagine being in a room and
listening to your dad
beating your mum you're never going to
get that out of your head
you're never going to get over that
for many months now we've been
investigating how domestic abuse victims
are treated by the authorities how do
you think domestic abuse victims are
treated
like dirt
we hear the testimonies of several women
who instead of being cared for like
victims say they're being dealt with as
if they are the perpetrator
and we discover the cost of living
crisis is responsible for a whole new
wave of cases the cost of living extra
stress it's more scary you walk in the
door you don't know what you're going to
get new research reveals that nearly all
the new victims are blaming the crisis
for their abuse getting worse
and the abusers are getting away with it
time and time again despite the huge
rise in cases the number of prosecutions
are actually going down
i have young people who says um no i
won't call the police and the crisis is
making an already desperate situation
worse
those that flee are being housed in
properties that are barely livable the
client ceiling has fell through over the
weekend
[Music]
my name is gene hatchett i'm a domestic
abuse survivor
um i was in a
i was abused for
well over a decade
when i first met him he was charming and
convincing
he swept off my feet he was funny made
me feel like the center of his universe
it changed
quite
quite quickly and he broke my ribs
within the first year
even if you can cover up all the
physical violence the tension
over the years in that household of a
mother who's trying to exist with an
abuser
has a deep and lasting
impact on that child so you you are
constantly constantly battling to keep
yourself safe and to keep your kids safe
and then you come up against the beast
you know just when you think you've got
it all sorted you're out there is a
beast in this country that keeps women
perpetually abused and it's called
family court
and women get smashed to the ground in
that place on a daily basis
it's the last tool he can use and he'll
use it through financial means when he's
negotiating in the divorce he'll drag
women back and forth to court or arguing
about
this and that you know that your life
will never be the same again when you
leave an abuser
you don't know quite how badly it will
never be the same again but
you're never quite prepared
domestic abuse charities have told us
that demand for their support has risen
by a third since the cost of living
crisis kicked in earlier this year
the national helpline has never been
busier there's often a five-hour wait to
get through to a support worker
new research by women's aid says that 96
percent of victims say the cost of
living has made their abuse worse
and nearly three-quarters say they can't
afford to leave their abusive home
so what is domestic violence or abuse it
was three years ago when rosie duffield
gave her testimony in the house of
commons
domestic violence has many faces and the
faces of those who survive it are varied
too i just thought soju
just kind of felt like
what's the point of me if i don't speak
up for other women and just did it
so one night
after more crying and being constantly
verbally abused because you suggest that
he helped pay a bit towards your new
sofa
you realize you've reached the end and
you simply cannot endure this for
another day or week and certainly not
for the rest of your life
so if anyone's watching and needs a
friend please reach out if it's safe to
do so and please talk to any of us
because we'll be there and we'll hold
you home
ever since the labour mp told her story
her inbox has been constantly full of
other victims asking for help every
single day since then every single day
it's been about
three
three years i think nearly and i still
get i got an email last night about two
in the morning actually from a woman
saying she didn't know what to do more
women are coming forward
what factors do you think are
contributing to this recent rise i think
the cost of living crisis is an obvious
one if there are all those factors like
the cost of living extra stress
job insecurity all of those things it's
more scary you walk in the door you
don't know what you're going to get all
of those triggers which somebody with a
bad temper is going to use as an excuse
in their head to take it out and you if
they're that kind of person all of those
things contribute and make you less safe
and more unstable and more scared
jennifer mcdermott runs the cassandra
center in south london
this is our therapy room
it supports domestic abuse victims
and it's named after her daughter
cassandra was my daughter
she was 19
when she was killed
[Music]
cassie was beaten to death
by
a hex partner
horrendous
to know that
she died alone
i suppose the pain
the
you can't comprehend i can't just can't
comprehend at all
that's my mission to prevent
any other young person
like cassie being
ended up in the same fate as she has
mario solaire was acquitted of
cassandra's murder but he was finally
convicted seven years later when police
reopened the case after he attacked
another woman
despite the recent rise in cases caused
by the cost of living crisis the number
of prosecutions for domestic abuse are
down by six percent it's a familiar
story for the people here
i have young people who
have been through horrendous offences
and victims of um offenses victim of
rape
and who says um no i won't call the
police because they do nothing
caseworker sophie jones fights many of
the battles the victims can't fight for
themselves
one of her clients recently fled after
the abuse got worse
the client's ceiling has fell through
over the weekend
this is really serious
and i don't think you understand would
you like it if you was in a predicament
where your ceiling has fallen through
over the weekend and nobody's attended
the property
okay no worries i will send another
email and i will be following this up
later on today
okay thank you
one of my clients property
um the ceiling collapsed over the
weekend um she's a dv survivor she's
been placing awful temporary
accommodation and now the ceiling's
collapsed and the local authority are
saying oh somebody will be there soon
but we are on wednesday
nothing's happening not whatsoever this
makes you angry doesn't it yeah furious
what percentage of women that you deal
with have kids
probably about 90
could you imagine being in a room and
listening to your dad
beating your mum you're never going to
get that out of your head
you're never going to get over that no
matter how much therapy is offered these
children are going to suffer for the
rest of their life
we're off to one of my clients
asha who has just got a new property
after being stuck in horrific conditions
accommodation
for two years
sky news has already met this family we
documented their windowless room with
ant infestations in a broken bathroom
you go first go it's okay
oh
asha
it's lovely
[Music]
we've been invited back to meet the
family at their new property i love your
new place
it's great isn't it yeah much bigger
i sat down with 14 year old ahmed
this is the first thing that's resembled
a home for him since the family fled
their father four years ago
what's it like being a child
um
from a
relationship which was so full of abuse
i have seen the inner depths of hell and
i don't and back then i used to think
there is no heaven there's no lights out
of the tunnel
and then
now in this current situation
the council has offered us a very nice
suitable accommodation
finally i can breathe the same air that
other humans are breathing and
i can finally live like a normal person
the housing of domestic abuse victims
has always been a problem but the cost
of living crisis is making it worse
thousands of women and young children
are left in limbo with no permanent home
passed around refuges and temporary
accommodations
i've come to meet a victim who fled her
abusive home seven years ago with a
young son
and they've still not been offered a
permanent home
karen left after police warned her that
she could be killed by a partner
he was acquitted of abusing her
i
naively assumed that when you were in
that much of a
dangerous situation
that there was this net
to hold you to grab you
unfortunately
it didn't happen
you're trying to explain that your son
is really traumatized and he needs a
home
and he can't deal with it anymore
he's been
moved
six times
in seven years
and he's just he's so unhappy
he's so unhappy
he has no faith in
the system in authority
in
in anything
why do you think that
vulnerable women and children are being
treated like this
because they they expect us not to speak
up
it's easy isn't it
i don't
i'm here
but i need to be anonymized because i'm
scared of my ex-partner
because i'm seven years down the road i
now want i want to speak
and i'm still scared but the need to
speak and and tell people how it really
is
um
it's just really strong because it's not
right
the government knows there's a problem
here
they've invested more than 230 million
pounds into tackling domestic abuse in
the last 18 months
but there's been no more money since the
cost of living crisis took hold
and the money that is there hasn't yet
filtered down to the people who matter
the most
this is a cycle that if we don't stop
it's never going to stop
this crisis isn't going away any time
soon
all the victims can do is ask the people
in power for more help
do you think that politics
sometimes gets in the way of actually
helping yeah victims yeah of course
we're so busy shouting each other across
the chamber and actually while we're
doing that those people like i've said
are trying to survive and get on with
their lives
that's pretty pathetic isn't it
we need to do better than
you